if brexit top of the agenda at a party
conference gets underway the Prime
Minister will announce the plan to end
the authority of European laws in
Britain as well well joining me from
there is a cabinet minister
international development secretary
Priti Patel and a very good morning to
you Secretary of State
right then article 50 triggered by the
end of March next year that there are
those though on your side of the
referendum argument pretty bitterly say
well given that the EU won't negotiate
with us until we formally trigger
article 50 what is there to wait for why
not do it now well look you've heard the
Prime Minister speak this morning she
has said and she's speaking today she's
giving her speech today where she will
outline she's going to say that article
50 will be triggered at the end of next
March but we are also saying that we are
going to start the process by repealing
the European communities act of 1972 and
of course this is at the right approach
because now this will give a very smooth
and orderly process in terms of the
negotiations that will follow that will
also lead to the triggering of article
50 get on tonight in a moment but you're
staying with article 56 months more
adrift though you will have heard the
warnings from major car manufacturers
last week saying they need some
certainty as they make crucial
investment decisions for production and
ultimately for jobs six months is quite
a long time when those decisions are in
the balance well we are already speaking
to businesses and you know manufacturing
firms in fact my colleague David Davis
and other cabinet colleagues are having
active discussions with them so we're
working to give certainty and I think
the fact that we have announced already
that we're going to repeal the European
communities act we've now got a clear
indication as to when article 50 will be
triggered that gives a certainty and
importantly it gives confidence as to
businesses when it comes to investment
decisions but also it gives clarity now
going forward in terms of regulations
and legislation that we will ultimately
stick with and the ones that we will
look to through this entire process of
repealing the European communities act
look to change to make sure that we are
working in our national interests and
delivering the best deal for Britain
well answer that question then for me
Brittany Patel what will the government
do with the six months before
two-fifty is triggered as I said given
the AU's official position and we've
heard it from so many quarters within EU
member countries that they will not have
any pre negotiations well look I mean we
can't we come on we're not going to give
a running commentary in terms of what
other European nations and countries are
saying our Prime Minister has given the
greatest degree of clarity in terms of
what we are doing and actually we are
going to deliver brexit for the British
public which is exactly what they voted
for and at the same time we're outlining
now the approach that we are taking we
are going to repeal the European
communities act which article 50 will be
triggered next year by the end of March
and there is a there is a whole raft of
work that's taking place across
Whitehall across government departments
who are here from David Davis later on
today as well where he you know will
speak much more about the approach that
we are taking across government
government departments in particular and
looking at the raft of legislation that
will feature in terms of the negotiation
and also the repeal of the European
communities act let's talk about that so
great repeal bill as it's being called
now so as we understand it then that the
bill goes through but the laws remain
until the formal exit takes place
sometime in 2019 well we are saying that
we are going to repeal the legislation
the European communities act which of
course took us into the membership of
the European Union and basically meant
that our laws and regulations were
determined by the European Union so we
will publish a bill a bill in the next
Queen's speech and by publishing that
bill we will set the framework and make
it quite clear that obviously we will
keep the laws that currently exist and
start working across every single
government department and those
discussions are taking place now work
across in government departments to see
where we need to you know change make
the changes on outdated regulation
legislation and the things that simply
do not work in our national interest so
right so keep all those laws as you said
they're prepared to repeal them and then
unpick them one by one have you got any
estimate about how long all that will
take well there'll be a parliamentary
process
of course engineer that's the point of
having legislation you have clauses you
have a bill and we will work through
that process the point that I would
emphasize is of course that is now the
work that's being undertaken through the
department to leave the European Union
Union in terms of working with every
single government department you know
let's not forget we've had legislation
over 44 years so there'll be a lot of
legislation but also there'll be some
outdated legislations as well that will
need to come off the statute book and we
will make sure that we have the right
legislation you know we're going to give
Parliament its sovereignty back we're
going to be making sure that we are
control of British laws in a way in
which we simply have not been because of
our membership of the European Union